- [Instructor] Duncan is
investigating if residence
of a city support the
construction of a new high school.
He's curious about the
difference of opinion
between residence in the north
and south parts of the city.
He obtained separate
random samples of voters
from each region, here are the results.
So let's see, in the
north 54 out of the 120
said they want the school,
66 said they didn't.
In the south 77 said
they wanted the school,
63 said they didn't.
Duncan wants to use these
results to construct
a 90% confidence interval to estimate
the difference in the
proportion of residence
in these regions who support
the construction project.
P sub S minus P sub N.
So these are the true
parameters for the difference
between these two populations.
Assume that all of the
conditions for inference
have been met.
Alright, which of the
following is a correct
90% confidence interval
based on Duncan's sample?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out
and you will need a calculator
and depending on your calculator
you might need a Z table as well.
In a previous video we introduced the idea
of a two sample Z interval
and we talked about
the conditions for inference.
Lucky for us here they say the conditions
for inference have been met.
So we can go straight to calculating
the confidence interval.
And that confidence
interval is going to be
the difference between
the sample proportions,
so P sub S hat, so the sample
proportion in the south
minus the sample proportion in the north,
it's gonna be that
difference plus or minus
our critical value, Z
star, times our estimate
of the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the difference between
the sample proportions.
And that is going to be our estimate
is going to be P hat sub S times one minus
P hat sub S, all of that over
the sample size in the south
plus P hat sub N times
one minus P hat sub N,
all of that over the
sample size in the north.
Okay, so our sample
proportion in the south,
I'll later use a calculator
to get a decimal value,
but this is going to be in the south
we have 77 out of 140 support it.
So this is going to be 77 out of 140.
In the north this is
going to be 54 out of 120,
54 out of 120.
What is my critical Z value?
Well here I'm gonna have
to either use a calculator
or a Z table.
Remember, we have a 90%
confidence interval.
And so, let me see, I'll
draw it right over here.
If this is a normal distribution
and you wanna have a
90% confidence interval
that means you're containing 90%
of the distribution which
means each of these tails
well combined they would have 10%,
but each of them would have
5% of the distribution.
And so I'm gonna look at a Z table
that figures out how
many standard deviations
below the mean do I need to be
in order to get 5% right over here?
And then that's going to tell me,
well if I'm that far below or above
that's gonna be my critical Z value.
So let me get that Z table out.
So I care about 5% and
I'm using this in a bit
of a reverse direction, but let's see, 5%.
So this a little over
5%, I'm getting closer
to 5%, even closer to 5%, now
we've gotten right below 5%.
So we're gonna be in
between this and this.
I could just split the difference
and I could just say,
1.6, let's just say 1.645
to go right in between.
So this is going to be
approximately equal to 1.645.
And then let's see, we
know what P hat sub S is,
we know what P hat sub N is.
In the south our sample size is 140
and in the north our sample size is 120.
And so now I just have to type all of this
into the calculator, which
is gonna get a little hairy,
but we will do it together.
For the sake of time we'll accelerate
this typing into the calculator.
But I'm gonna start with
calculating the upper bound
and then we'll calculate the lower bound.
And then I think I've
closed all my parentheses
and so I think we're ready
to get the upper bound
is going to be equal to
0.218 or approximately 0.202.
So we can immediately look at our choices
and see where is at the upper bound.
And so this one is looking
pretty good, 0.202,
but let's get the lower bound now.
So I got my calculator back,
instead of retyping everything
I'm just gonna put a minus here.
So I go to second, and just
so you see what I'm doing,
second entry, I see the entry back
and then I can just
change, I can just change
the part where right before the radical.
So we are going to, alright,
so this just needs to be
a minus, click enter,
and there you have it.
Our lower bound is negative 0.002.
And that is indeed this
choice right over here.
So there we go, we have picked our choice.